robinson lair for an inning getting his
first start for boston tonight and
swanson will lead things off
cut on and miss that was pretty nasty to
strike him out swanson retired freddie
freeman 15-game hitting streak 21 hits
ripped into right and it's gonna drop in
front of her dugo and a backhanded
otherwise that would have
skipped past him to the right field wall
so it's a 16-game hitting streak for
freddie freeman here's darnold he's been
atlanta's best man with runners in
scoring position
swing in a miss struck him out with a
breaking ball
and he leaves two aboard in his one
inning erlin making his seventh
appearance of the season that sucks lead
off man on for debra's
going the other way he's going to find
the gap and that's down on the grass the
track up against the wall that bounces
away from inciarte here comes the ron
verdugo rounding and he is in the score
and the red sox take the lead one to
nothing deborah's at seconds and a bow
guards at first martinez just 208
there's a bullet
that one's going to be socked to the gap
to the base of the wall that'll chase
endeavors
beau bogarts to third stopping there and
jd martinez hit it right on the screws
red sox had second and third two runs
home and chavis next base hit could mean
a couple
he's going to line that one to center
field and hangs up for inciarte he'll
make the catch tagging up xander bogarts
he is in the score
rbi for chavis that makes it three to
nothing boston well here comes mike
kickham first appearance for the red sox
starting with austin reilly
and riley shoots it the other way that's
down the line verdugo will try to cut it
off before the wall he did riley
chugging for two he's going to slide in
safely and riley is spraying the ball
from line to line good start for atlanta
in the second it's a lead-off double for
austin riley it's adam duvall
and a high fly ball belted it's going to
be a one-run game adam duvall hits it
over the green monster it's 3-2 that's
his second home run of the series those
are his only two hits in the series they
have the tying run at first base
swanson will jump on this one headed
high up to the monster and that ball oh
leaping catch
jackie bradley jr with a magnificent
play
as he went rising up there at the base
of the wall and made a great catch well
he is a highlight film i mean he really
is and the braves have him first and
third with two outs here's ozuna who
walked his first timer and ozuna shoots
that through the hole on the right side
that's going to tie the game freddie's
going to go first to third 3-3 ozuna
having himself a whale of a time at
fenway park so far two home runs for
jackie on the year
high fly ball out there to center field
looking up they are to the wall
and that ball is going to rattle around
in the seats it is gone a home run for
jackie bradley jr number three
to put the red sox in the lead 4-3
another left-handed pitcher bradley jr
takes deep this ball gets high up off
the bat skied that ball i didn't know if
it was going to get out of here or not
2-1 jd martinez an rbi double he's also
fly to center stocks trying to add on
he'll flare that one into right field
that drops down for a hit
roduga rounding third here's the throw
to the plate he will dive in safely
rbi for martinez is second of the ball
game red sox open up a 5-3 lead
duvall he represents the tying run he's
already hit one two run homer
lifted toward left martinez going back
he's going to turn that ball is gone
duval has a second two run homer and the
braves have tied the game in the sixth
two homers four rbis for duval and new
life for atlanta lead off man
play on down to second jack he's safe
got that left hand in there
well he swept that tag i don't know if
he got there in time
the throw was the opposite side of the
bag but great tag there by camargo
verdugo
who's been on three times tonight he
walked and scored in the first and here
it is swaying animus pulled a string and
verdugo not happy about that
5-5 game after six at fenway park and it
brings up marcel ozuna who hasn't
homered all night
as ozuna goes into launch mode he's got
another one at fenway park way out of
here in atlanta's in front that's his
12th of the year and it's six to five
braves adam duvall steps in against
brazier
as another high fly ball wallop towards
center bradley goes to the wall it's
gone duvall has a three-run night
another home run for duvall two two run
homers now a solo shot and marcelo zuna
sing anything you can do i can do better
wow 7-5 the top of the order and the guy
that has given the braves the most
trouble in this series that's alex
verdugo 2-1 pitch on the way
swinging a miss
and that is strike three and the braves
have swept the boston red sox